How important
is purpose,
reason or cause in being successful?
Like the purpose,
your purpose,
right?
Well clearly purpose and reason and cause are extremely important.
This is,
this is the why of of your actions.
This is knowing why you're doing what you're doing.
This is the commander's intent.
And so you,
you absolutely,
absolutely,
these are important.
If you don't know why you're doing something,
well then let me ask you a question.
Why are you doing something?
It does.
It's very clear.
It's very simple to understand.
So yeah,
you got to know if,
if you don't know why you're doing something and then what,
what are you going to do when you hit an obstacle?
You're going to stop.
What do you,
what,
uh,
what adaptations are you gonna make when things go wrong to overcome them?
You're not going to make any cause you don't know why you're doing it.
Yeah.
So if you have no reason,
if you have no reason for doing something,
you're not going to do it.
So you got to have a longterm goal.
We've got to understand the underlying purpose of what you're doing.
Now,
this doesn't necessarily mean that it mean that it has to be rigid because it
doesn't have to be rigid.
You know,
I'll tell you an interesting case as an example I'll give you is my own case,
right?
So of course,
you know,
I'm all about planning in and always having a longterm plan and all that stuff.
But to be honest with you,
the situation that I'm in right now as a human,
I didn't have a long term plan for this.
You know,
the,
I,
you know,
Leif and I wrote the book,
I had no intention of writing a book that kind of happened,
you know,
cause people were asking us and as we worked with businesses,
they said you have this stuff written down.
So we ended up writing the book.
Once we wrote it,
we thought maybe we'd be handing it out when we go and work with companies
literary agent saw today,
let me,
let me show this to some publishers.
Publishers on said,
let us publish this.
Okay,
so you figure you're going to publish it.
Well,
even when you publish a book,
you don't expect it.
A bunch of people are gonna read it.
You expect that you're going to have a book published and that's cool,
but it ended up doing really well.
So that kind of happened with that.
All of a sudden I was on a couple of podcasts.
Well,
I didn't,
you know,
I didn't have any intention when I went on and Tim Ferriss,
his podcast,
I didn't say to myself,
this is going to propel me into my own podcast,
or Joe Rogan's Patty and say,
now you know Joe Rogan's going to launch me into the podcast world.
No,
I didn't expect that,
but it happened and you know what?
It happened.
It made sense to me.
Okay,
these two guys are squared away.
They're squared away in this particular genre and they're recommending my mind
is open.
Okay,
let's try and make a podcast.
Did I know that the podcast was going to be super popular?
No,
I just thought we were making a podcast so that you know,
the few people want would want to listen to it.
Cool for.
I mean,
then look what happens.
Next thing you know,
we're,
we're making tea,
you know,
next thing I'm making tea.
I had no,
no idea that that t would be part of my world.
So
all this stuff happened,
right?
But,
but the goal,
really the underlying,
the reason for me doing all this is still the same through the whole thing.
And that is that I want to help people.
I want to help people with something that,
the lessons that I've learned,
I want to help them.
So how can I do that?
Well,
you write them down.
Okay,
you wrote it down so people can read it.
Great.
How else can you help them?
Oh,
you can make a podcast so people can access it easily and cheaply.
Cool.
Here you go.
So the underlying go,
oh,
you know,
I want people to be healthy.
Well,
what's a good way to be healthy?
Stop drinking monster energy drinks.
Stop Drinking Red Bull 12 a day and start drinking something that's healthier.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
Jocko white tea.
Next thing you know,
that's what we've got going on.
So it's,
it's,
that's been my,
that's been my goal and I haven't really,
even though I,
even though I strayed from what maybe the original path I thought I was going to
take and I still stayed,
my reason is the same.
And I think that that's what I'm saying.
When your reason is clear and your purpose is clear,
that's going to make your drive clear and that's gonna make you execute well
because you know where you're going,
you know you where you want to be,
you understand your purpose and why you're doing something and that's what's
going to help you be successful in my opinion.
Do you think
that like,
oh,
um,
you know,
people,
they'll be like,
this is my why and it'll be like their kids or something like that.
Do you think that falls within this like,
you know,
like reason,
purpose and all this stuff?
Yeah,
I think,
I think that that's the same,
the same general,
that guy could have said purpose,
reason,
cause of why I think that that the question could have said that.
I think that if your purpose is your kids really clear example,
right?
I have a lot of people might say that.
Well that's cool but that's,
you're going to have to clarify that a little bit more because if your purpose
is your kids then quit your job and just spend all day with your kids,
well then obviously you're not supporting your kids cause now you can't afford
to buy him food.
So your,
your goal should be taking good care of and providing for your children's now
and in the future.
Wow.
Okay.
Now that makes sense.
Now you're looking longterm,
short term,
you gotta you know that you have to work hard now you don't have to make
investments with them.
So that,
that's the kind of thing that's beyond just a simple,
I'm doing this for my kids cause why are you doing for your kids?
What are you trying to achieve for them?
Yeah.
So like for using that example,
like this is my why,
it's my daughter,
it's less.
This is why I'm,
you know,
I don't know,
writing a book,
it's more,
this is why I can endure the hard days,
or this is why I'm gonna continue to work hard kind of thing.
Whatever it is I'm doing.
Yeah.
And I just have an underlying yes and underlying reason.
That's,
that's a question that I think that's the answer.
Yes.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
I actually,
I should've just answered that into words.
I should have said.
How important is purpose,
reason causing being successful?
Answer.
Very important.
There we go.
You can have a lot of different reasons to,
you know,
or like a few core read more than one instance.
Yeah.
You know what I'd say if there's anything to be taken away from this question,
ed is,
if you don't feel,
here's the,
I would say the takeaway.
If you don't feel some kind of drive in your life,
if you don't feel passionate about something,
if you feel like you're wandering and meandering through the world,
then it's time to assess.
Then it's time to say,
okay,
what is my reason?
What am I trying to do?
What would I like to do in the world?
Now we get something valuable here.
Yeah,
hold on.
We all know that you've got to have a purpose.
Are y'all going to get out of reasons?
So if you feel yourself meandering down the path with no reason,
no purpose,
dig in and find one.